you
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the king tide that was
last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
[Music]
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
[Music]
Barry Allen persuade said that like it
explains why there's a total stranger
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair he said he'll fight with
us more or less more or more or less
probably more or less he said no they
said no look man I don't know who you
are but whoever you're looking for
[Music]
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities see
I believe enemies are coming and stop
right there
I'm in you are just like that yeah I
need friends right
I hate this
[Applause]
I heard about you didn't think you were
real
I'm realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
[Music]
you